ABCs of AI O is for optical character
recognition optical character
recognition or OCR is the conversion of
images of handwritten typed or printed
text into machine learning encoded text
never heard of it before well you've
likely used it Google uses OCR in a
variety of products and services Google
search uses OCR to index text from
images and its search results Google
Cloud Vision API provides an OCR service
that can be used to extract text from
images and videos Google Lens uses OCR
to identify objects and extract text
from images Google translate uses o R to
extract and translate text from docs and
images and so much more OCR technology
is now Advanced enough to be able to
recognize text with high accuracy even
in challenging conditions for example
OCR systems can now recognize text from
images that are blurry noisy or
distorted yes even my handwriting which
means developers can use OCR to easily
build applications to make our lives
easier more accessible and efficient and
that's this week's letter for